Welcome to Academy Dialogues.
It starts with us.
My name is Shawn
Finnie, and we're
about to get into the
second in our continuing
series of conversations about
race, ethnicity, identity,
history, and the opportunity
and the art of filmmaking.
Our theme today is Native Son.
Native Son was founded by
veteran magazine editor,
cultural change-maker, and
LGBTQ activist Emil Wilbekin,
with the intention to create
a safe space for Black gay men
to celebrate our achievements,
build community, and inspire
one another.
We are so grateful to
have Emil moderating
today's conversation,
which will focus
on growing the voice and the
visibility of Black gay men
in Hollywood and
the film industry.
Emil has held
editor-in-chief positions
at Vibe and Giant magazine,
been both managing
editor and editor-at-large at
Essence, style guru at Complex,
and chief content officer for
the annual Afropunk festival.
Speaking with Emil are
writer/director/producer Lee
Daniels and writer
Tarell Alvin McCraney,
who have agreed to
share their stories.
Lee directed the film Precious--
Based on the Novel
"Push" by Sapphire.
Precious received six
Oscar nominations,
including Best Picture, and
took home two Oscars that night
for Best Supporting
Actress and made history
with the Best Adapted Screenplay
win, making Geoffrey Fletcher
the first ever
African-American man
to win an Oscar for writing.
He also produced Monster's Ball,
for which Halle Berry became
the first, and so
far only, Black woman
to win a Best Actress Oscar.
He also created the TV series
Empire and Star, both of which
he produces and directs.
Tarell Alvin McCraney is
an Academy Award winner
for Best Adapted Screenplay for
the film Moonlight, for which
he co-wrote based on his play
In the Moonlight Black Boys Look
Blue.
He also wrote High Flying Bird,
directed by Steven Soderbergh,
which was released
on Netflix last year.
Thank you all for participating
in Academy Dialogues
and for sharing your stories.
We look forward to
your conversation.
Well, thank you, gentlemen,
for being here with us today.
Our topic is the growing
voice and visibility
of Black gay men in Hollywood
and in the film industry.
You know, as Black gay men, we
live in triple consciousness.
We're Black, we're
gay, and we're men.
And particularly as we move
through the world right now,
all of those things come into
play at every intersection.
Native Son is framed after
James Baldwin's Notes
of a Native Son.
And it's very interesting that
within Notes of a Native Son
he criticizes portrayals of
black people in Hollywood
and notably talks a lot about
Dorothy Dandridge in Carmen
Jones.
Why is it important that
we have this conversation
about Black gay men
and our identity
and our sexuality
and our masculinity
and amplify our voice and
visibility in Hollywood?
Lee, let's start with you.
First off, what was the read on
Dorothy Dandridge, may I ask?
What was he saying
about Dorothy Dandridge?
It was more of how Black people
were depicted in Carmen Jones.
And so are we showing
full pictures?
Are we sexualized?
How are we showing black people?
And I think that's something
that we all grapple with today.
Mm-hmm.
Now, I was so into
the Carmen Jones of it
all that I forgot the question.
One more time.
Sum it up real quick.
Yes.
So why is it important for us
to have these conversations
as Black gay men about our
masculinity, our identity,
and our sexuality and amplify
our voice and visibility
in Hollywood,
especially right now?
Because this is where
it starts, right here.
This is all where it
starts, right here.
There is a conception,
or a misconception,
of what the African-American
gay male is.
And not everybody looks
like or acts like what
they perceive us to be.
I mean, it's a hard question.
It's like--
A really hard question.
I want to make sure I'm clear.
Also, I think a part of what I
think some of the question is--
and, Lee, I'd love to hear
what you have to say about it--
is how do we get
to a place where
we're talking to each other.
Like, so many of the
questions and so many
of what we want to
talk about is always
asking Hollywood to
give us something
or to make space for us.
And it's like-- and it gets
harder because we're constantly
begging for space to be human.
Like, give us room so we
can be all the many versions
of ourselves.
Something that you alluded
to many times when we talked
is that, look, there
is as many versions
of being Black and gay as
there are Black and gay people.
There are many versions of it.
And if you just
show one version,
then you are limiting that
people's history and humanity
to that just narrow scope.
And we shouldn't have to ask
to get a little bit more space
to show all the variations.
We shouldn't have to
keep begging for that.
And so it's a hard question
to ask, because it's like,
well, we've been asking
for almost 400 years.
And from theater to music
to film to the internet,
we keep getting these
sort of narrow channels
to be fully human.
And I think that's why it's
a hard question to answer.
And, Lee, you've been doing
it way longer than I have.
Thank you for that.
Thank you for that,
Tarell, because it threw me
for a little bit of a loop.
Yeah, I mean, it's
like peeling an onion.
It's like peeling an onion.
It's so layered and so
complicated, that question,
Emil.
It is very, very difficult
doing what we do.
It is very, very
difficult having
to face your own people--
forget about white people,
forget about Hollywood--
but your own people
as a Black gay man,
as a masculine walking Black
gay man, because people
are thrown by it.
They don't really see, or
they don't want to see--
it confuses people.
It throws people off.
And yeah.
So one of the things that I want
to ask both of you is that--
within Native Son, we talk
about this in Hollywood.
We talk about it in corporate
America and in media.
There is a sense of isolation.
We still live in this, we're
the only one in the room.
It could be at Yale.
It could be at Fox or at Amazon,
wherever you're working--
Netflix.
We're the only ones.
And so how do you navigate
being the only one
and telling your story
without fear of being quieted?
I think, for me--
I can't speak for Tarell--
but for me, I grew
up in the streets.
I grew up with a
family of drug dealers.
I grew up unafraid.
And I took that
unafraidness into my concept
of how to break into Hollywood.
No one was going to tell
me that I was nothing,
or I wasn't going to
have anybody tell me
that I wasn't worthy of it.
And look, it starts
with talent first.
You have to have talent.
I think you can't just fake it.
You have to have something
that God has given you
that you know that you can
count on at the end of the day.
And once you have that--
I'm just speaking for me--
once you have what
you think is talent,
that is your backbone
for getting in the room,
as Malcolm X says, by
any means necessary.
So I didn't-- by any means
necessary is how I got
into the rooms--
by any means necessary.
I was going to do what I had
to do to get into the room,
so that--
I was going to do what
I had to do to make sure
that Monster's Ball got into
existence, that Halle Berry won
the Academy Award-- by
any means necessary.
And so now it doesn't really--
it's not about by
any means necessary.
But I will resort to
that if I have to.
Right.
But do you find, now
that you're in the room,
that you're still the only
Black gay man in the room who
is presenting these
stories that are other,
that are the story, the
narratives that we never hear?
Well, I surround myself now
with as many Black gay men
as I can so I'm not the
only one in the room when
I'm creating these stories.
But when I'm pitching
these stories,
oftentimes that is the case.
And it is-- it's
really interesting.
This generation today,
we're in a different space
where people just are
accepting anything
as talent because it's
other, as opposed to looking
at the talent now.
Now, the message is woke,
as opposed to the talent.
Is it woke?
OK, let's do it.
Let's do it.
So a lot of people are
getting passes on mediocrity--
gay people and Black people.
But no, you have to
be born with a talent.
You have to be--
it's a gift from God that
that drives you forward
into the room.
It propels you into
a space where that--
and I can only,
again, speak for me--
where you do not take
no for an answer.
And this is going
to happen my way.
Right.
So, Tarell, what about you?
Being the only one
in the room, how
do you navigate that
from a creative space,
from an empowering space,
from a survival space?
Well, first of all, I think
white people have been allowed
mediocrity for 400 years.
And I think-- so I think I'm all
right with a little mediocrity
here and there from us.
We've had to be super
and over-talented
in every way, shape, or form.
And so I think I
don't mind so much.
I also am very much--
like Lee said, I
make sure when I
do say I'm blessed and
lucky and fortunate
and had people like Lee
and like many people
before me to make
spaces for me and inform
the stories I want to tell.
And in that way,
I'm able to say, no,
you can't fill my room with
as many white executives
as you want.
I actually would like
for you to fill it with--
it's almost as if--
and it was so funny,
because my best friend
and I were having
this conversation.
I really wanted to do--
I wanted to work
with some writers,
some Black gay writers,
who we respect.
We're around the same age.
We respect each other's work.
And when I said, hey, we all
want to do a project together,
people looked at me
like I was crazy,
because you're just
not allowed to put
that many of the same thing
in the room when it's black.
You can't put that--
you're going to put all
of them in the same room
and let them do something?
That's wild.
But as Lee said,
you sometimes just
have to keep saying
no until the room
looks more and more like you.
You keep saying no to
all of the other reasons
why you should go with this
tried and true method that--
rather than the unpaved ground,
the ground that's untrodden.
And so I deal with
it in that way.
And unlikely, I'm not
as brave all the time.
You know, I do get scared.
And I get scared
because I want to make
sure I'm protecting folk.
People are vicious.
People are vicious and mean.
And I don't want to
bring anybody up and not
be able to protect them.
And so you just look around.
You're just bringing people to
a place, and they're not ready
and not looking out
for all the things
that this very capitalist,
very hungry industry can do.
You sometimes watch a friend
get really hurt by other stuff.
And I think, you
know, anything--
bell hooks has a
saying about anything
that estranges us or
alienates us one from another,
it serves the interests of
racism and discrimination.
And I just--
I'm a protector in that way.
So I try my best to make sure,
hey, if I'm bringing you along,
I want to make sure that
we're in this together,
and that I have enough
energy and strength
and focus that I can make sure
that we're all doing our best
work here on sort of just--
as free as we can be.
I was about to say free.
But you know, in America,
there's such a tax on that word
now.
We don't even know if
we can use it anymore.
Are we really free?
But we're trying to get there.
I'm trying to get free.
Tarell, that's why
I love you, man.
I mean, the idea--
and it's a total
generational thing.
Like, I would have never thought
to think of the mediocrity
that white people have put out.
This is the--
I mean, of course,
it's a no-brainer.
It is a no-brainer.
But we have been
trained, brainwashed
to believe that we have
to be the best that we
are in whatever it is.
If they are good, we
have to be even better.
So already that comment right
there shows the disconnect
from my generation
to your generation,
and thank you for
correcting me on that.
And that's good.
It's part of-- no,
it's an evolution.
I am learning so
much from this change
that's happening right now.
Because I approached
the rooms, I
approached getting projects
done in such a iconoclastic way.
It just wasn't-- it was
by any means necessary.
And then when I was on, I
had to make sure that once it
was done that it was perfect.
So I won't be so
hard, I guess, on some
of the African-American-- some
of the Black stuff that I've
seen.
I'm hard on it.
I'm hard on stuff,
anyway, but I'm extra hard
on what it is that we have.
And I shouldn't be.
This is a wake-up.
Thank you for that.
No, I think-- listen, I believe
we must make space so that we
can interrogate, we
can critique, we can--
but we need to do that together
and have those conversations.
That's how we grow.
That's how cultures grow.
Nothing gets a "pass."
Especially with us, we
can go to the barbershop,
and he going to have
five or six variations
on why that film didn't work.
I mean, I've had people sit
me down and tell me, ain't
seen a play ever in their life.
I was the first play they
ever went to on Broadway.
And then telling me, well,
you know, in that third act,
if you would've just did x.
And you know-- and that's OK.
I think there's moments.
But I think in terms of-- or
at least the way the question
was placed to me, in terms of
trying to live up to whatever
they need us to live up to
or trying to push something
uphill, it's like, yo,
if they highlight--
if they greenlighting stuff
that they don't know is mediocre
and there's a brother or a
sister getting paid for it,
I'm not about to
block anybody's money.
It's too rough out here.
But does that mean I don't
want to help and encourage
rigor and exploration of their
best art and their best form?
Of course, but that's for us.
I want you to do your
best not because I want
you to prove anything to them.
I want you to do
your best because it
will help us look at ourselves
and see who we are better.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
You mentioned, Tarell,
how gracious Lee was
and how he really sat you
down and talked to you.
And so it's funny,
Lee, to hear you--
Well, Lee doesn't sit
anybody down to talk to him.
[LAUGHS] Just rolls up on them.
Lee going to tell you on the--
Lee was like, come to set.
And while I'm doing
70 different things,
I'ma drop some gems on you.
So I don't know if there was
a sit-down, as opposed to,
you see that, don't do
that shit, moving on.
Right.
I get those calls all the time.
What were some of
the things that Lee
dropped on you and wisdom
that he shared with you
that helped you pave your way?
I just remember there was
one thing that Lee said--
there were many
things that Lee said.
But there was one thing that
Lee said that I actually
say to my students and
to myself consistently,
like a little mantra, which
is that they don't know us
better than we know us.
Don't ever let them make you
pretend or pay you enough money
to get you to say that
they actually know more
about us than they do.
You don't have-- and just like
I said about the nurse working
five shifts knows more
about Halle Berry's
struggle in Monster's Ball
than any executive does
and that she knows it.
She knows what that struggle is.
She knows what
that-- and so don't--
trust that.
You have to trust it.
You have to trust that you know
this life, this world, this--
even if it's fantasy,
even if it's sci-fi,
from this perspective you know
it, and you hold the key to it.
And it just helps me, because
there have been many a moment
where someone has
asked me to explain
my Blackness or my queerness
or my Black queerness.
And I've just been
like, I'm good today.
Like, I'm good on
explaining it today.
Like, you either
get it or you don't.
Or don't pay for it.
Don't greenlight it.
But I'm not explaining it today.
And I think I definitely
owe that to Lee.
Like, I hear him saying it in my
mind when those moments happen.
Thanks, Tarell.
Yeah, it's interesting, Lee--
Thank you.
Right.
We thank you, Lee, for sure.
It's interesting, Lee, that
you don't think that you are--
that you're not kind of
moving things forward
in a radical way.
I think that every
story that you've told
and every way that you
fundraised and cast,
you've always pushed
outside of the box
to create opportunities for
other Black gay storytellers
to come up, for
someone like Tarell
to be able to win the
Oscar for Moonlight
and for Jordan E. Cooper
to have an opportunity
to do storytelling.
Well, it comes second nature,
because the gift is not yours.
God didn't give you the gift.
The gift is that.
So your gift is to make
sure that it's passed on.
And you know, there was
a time in Hollywood,
when I came to Hollywood, where
you had to be the only one.
It was very competitive.
And I mean, I was the
only Black gay person that
was out at least, that
was out as a filmmaker.
But there was major competition
and the crabs in the barrel
thing amongst Black people.
And so you didn't
really pass it on.
It was all BS.
You really didn't pass it on.
But I knew instinctively,
as a gay man,
that I had to pass it
on, because otherwise I
would be the only one.
And I needed that to--
I needed that.
I knew that there
were people that
were far more talented
than me that were out there
that I really wanted--
far more talented than me that
I wanted to hear their voices.
And I wanted to
see that direction.
And I wanted to see
their productions.
And so if I didn't pass
it on, I was missing out
on the opportunity.
Does that make any sense?
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
How do we--
So I don't really look at it--
I'm sorry.
I don't really look at it as a--
for me it was survival.
It was about-- it is about--
it's never been about the money,
ever been about the money.
It is about making sure
that your work lives forever
and that I am affecting, in
particular, young Black kids
that are gay, in particular.
What message am I
sending to them?
That's what it's about.
Even if the situations
are provocative,
or if it's a sexual situation,
or if it's something
that they should--
like, what is it that will
make these kids think that they
also--
wow, this is a
world that I can see
that I know that we don't see.
What is Lee bringing to
us that we don't see?
And, Tarell, how do you--
And that's very scary.
That's scary, Emil, to do that.
Not to cut you off, but
that's really scary.
When you're in the middle
of that, I am afraid.
I'm not afraid of getting it.
Or I'm not afraid of--
I am not afraid of
getting the money
or convincing somebody
else to tell the story.
But once you're in the
middle of telling the story,
I am terrified.
And are you terrified because
you want it to be authentic,
that you want it to be healing?
I mean, what is--
All of the above.
Am I healing someone?
It's as close to
God as I get, when
I'm in that space of creating.
So I want to make sure that it
is definitely affecting you.
And if I'm in the face of God,
I am happy and I am afraid.
And then that fear then
drives the creativity as well?
Yes.
Sorry.
Go back to Tarell.
No, no, this is
the conversation.
So there's no start and stop.
Tarell, you talked about
bringing other Black talent
along.
How do you do that?
How do you do that through
your production deals?
How do you do that
as you're navigating
your own path in Hollywood?
I mean, there's no formula.
I think I just look around.
And every project
that I'm working on,
I try to make sure
that Black is--
that the people who
are working on it
are as Black as the story.
I mean, it's true.
I try to.
And sometimes I
don't get it 100%.
Sometimes the director might not
be Black, or some of the cast
might not be Black or some
of the grip or the DP.
But I try.
I really do try to
just go, oh, yo,
artist who's been
working in Chicago
and killing it for 20 years.
You've never had
a role like this.
Here, please take it.
And have to spend the
kind of time and effort
and making sure
people understand why
that this is such a pivotal
point for this artist.
But I just keep
pulling where I can.
And I do that pretty
unapologetically.
Now, like I said,
I'm not perfect,
and I definitely tire out.
So sometimes I fail.
Sometimes I don't
get it to the--
but I look to people
like Lee, to like
Ava, who figure out
ways to go, oh, no,
every director on this episode
is going to be a Black woman.
Or every DP or every camera
person is going to be x.
I try to get that
organizational voice.
But as Lee said, sometimes
when I get mired down
in the writing of
the thing, I just
get so focused on making sure
that the word is right that I
look up and I go, damn it.
I also need to pay attention
to these seven other things.
But if you don't--
for me it's also--
I need community,
for me personally.
I need to look--
I need to be able to
look around and go, hey,
there's [INAUDIBLE] to
someone who understands that
without having to explain it.
So I just try to move
with rather than solo.
And there's tempting
moments all the time
where people will go, oh,
come on through this door.
And then you try to come in, and
all your people come with you.
And they're like, oh,
not all y'all, just you.
And you kind of have to be
like, oh, well, we can't all--
I mean, I need them
in order to sit down.
I need them in
order to stay sane.
I need them in order not to
throttle you in five seconds
because they keep me easy.
And so you kind of have
to move as one sometimes.
And I know-- and
the saying is often,
like, oh, well, I'll
get through the door,
and then I'll open some for you.
It's like, well, sometimes
I just will stay outside
until we all can get in.
And I know people
have been like, well,
that's why you aren't
part of the Academy.
That's why you
aren't this and that.
I'm like, that's cool.
That's fine.
But I'll wait.
I'd rather wait till we all
can kind of walk on through.
So you're not apart
of the Academy,
but you have won an Oscar for
your writing for Moonlight.
This is so upsetting to even--
we talked about this earlier.
And it traumatized me.
That little rehearsal we
had, that conversation
that we had earlier when I got
that information spun me out
of control.
And it's indicative of the space
that we are in at the Academy.
We're trying.
Again, I bring it up because
that was a genuine conversation
that happened.
Someone literally said to
me, well, you need to fight.
You need to fight for your
position and your standing.
And I was like, well,
I'm sure there are
other people who didn't get--
I'm sure there's a list
of folks who didn't
walk through the threshold.
And I'd rather fight for
us than just my spot.
And what would it--
and again, it's
that thing about--
But, Tarell, let me just tell
you, you will be in the Academy
this year.
My God.
So that's a-- this is
a wrap conversation.
That's done.
Speaking of, let me just--
I'm going to talk about
your work for a second.
Wig Out!
You do feel alone.
Emil, I don't know
whether you saw the play.
Did you see the play?
I saw it.
[INAUDIBLE]
So I always feel
that I am alone.
I felt that way until
I saw this cat's work.
You just feel like--
the specificity of that
Black gay man's mind
is-- it's so specific.
It's just so-- the humor,
the banter, the pacing,
the everything.
I sat there and
watched that play.
I don't know where.
Was it the public?
Where was it at?
I don't know where it was at.
But it was--
It was at the venue.
Dude, let me tell you.
I saw the birth of a soul.
And I knew that--
it was a given.
And it made me feel so
good that I wasn't alone.
I've felt alone-- well,
George Wolfe's earlier works--
Colored Museum-- I felt
like, OK, he's out there.
But George was out there.
And then I saw this cat.
It was like, oh, man,
you're not alone.
And it's a really great
feeling to not be alone.
It's good.
And I'm sure that there--
Jordan Cooper's another.
Julian Breece is another.
It's what we have gone through.
It's what we've experienced
as Black gay men.
It's very specific, the feeling.
And when you are able to
express that in any form,
it's pretty breathtaking.
It's pretty groundbreaking.
It's what we bring to the table.
Yup.
Yup!
So how do we bring more
people to the table?
I mean, I understand
what Tarell's saying
about bringing people with him.
But what do you tell--
what's the advice
for young people
who want to become filmmakers,
who want to tell their stories,
but don't know how to get there?
What advice can we give them?
Wow, I mean, they
are teaching me.
I mean, the great news is that
these young people are not
waiting around for Tarell
to tell them to do nothing.
[? Barry ?] talks about
this all the time.
With just their phones, even
the ones that aren't the latest
iPhone or--
I mean, they can film quality
film and/or digital film
and stream it and
get entertainment.
I've seen seven seconds of drama
that has, like, blown me away.
And I go on these--
you'll see me sometimes.
I'll go on these
little GoFundMes.
And they'll be like, GoFundMe,
I'm doing a 20-minute short.
And I'll be like, your 20-minute
short's going to be amazing.
Here is the $5 that
I've got for you
to keep investing and doing it.
And they've democratized
film in a way
that I know a lot of
people are scared.
I know a lot of
gatekeepers are scared.
And I think rather than
run away from them,
we have to embrace their voices.
We have to embrace
what they have to say
and how they want to say it.
They're showing us new ways.
They're showing us new methods.
And I'm excited about it.
I don't know that I have
to tell them anything.
I think the job is what
Donny Hathaway said.
Teach them and let
them lead the way.
I love that.
I just wonder with that,
though, if we have an old guard
Hollywood, how do we get those
young, avant-garde, radical
filmmakers in front of these
other places to get money,
to get opportunities,
to be able to be seen?
Well, again, Emil,
it's not your gift.
It's not your gift.
It's your job.
It's my duty to seek
out these talents.
There's only so
many stories I have.
There's only so many stories
that I can even write
or I can be--
I can direct.
There's only so many.
But if you are seeking
out, then you'll find.
The internet is crazy.
I agree, Tarell.
I have cast more people,
I have hired more people,
from Instagram and from Twitter.
I would've never
thought that that
is the way now to find talent.
And they're unafraid.
There aren't any rules.
You're drawn in like, what
the hell, who thinks of this.
It's good.
Do you feel like marketers and--
But to your question,
Emil, about the old guard,
I mean, I don't know--
I mean, again, we
spend so much time--
I did this play called
Joan Jett Blakk for--
Ms. Blakk for
President in Chicago,
which is based on the life
of Terence Alan Smith, who
was Joan Jett Blakk, who got
on the floor of the 1992 DNC
in drag to run--
to launch a campaign for
Queer Nation for president
of the United States--
as far as we know,
the first Black drag queen to
run for president of the United
States.
And I was shocked and didn't
know anything about this story.
Found it, did this
play about it.
Found Terence Alan Smith living
in San Francisco and was just,
again, shocked at the
history that is lost.
I mean, their whole platform was
talking about the AIDS epidemic
at the time that was being
largely quelled or quieted
by the government, not
unlike what's happening today
in terms of COVID cases and
who's bearing the brunt of it
and whose communities
are really losing.
Anyway, the two things
that happened to me
were, one, I was once again
reminded of a generational loss
that we are still
suffering, grieving,
trying to find healing from.
There are so many between--
just a little older
than Lee, there's
so many men in
that generation who
were lost to the AIDS epidemic.
And that's so much talent gone.
And so the kind of passing
on that Lee talks about
isn't there, one.
But, two, there is this moment
where you have to stop--
well, I had to,
not anybody else.
It was a breakthrough moment.
I speak from a place that I--
I really had to stop trying
to think about, well,
how do I make this nice
enough for the old guard
to look at it.
I really had to go, I want
to spend the rest of my life
aiming all of my energy and
love and nurturing to people
I actually love and care about.
There was this
woman, this activist,
who calls herself
a D-word activist.
That's what she called herself.
And she was like, I spent the
first years of my life fighting
for people to--
fighting people who hated
me to try to love me.
And that doesn't really
make sense after a while.
You get to an age--
I'm about to be 40.
I'm like, I don't want
to spend the next 40
years of my life, 20 years of my
life aiming my energy at people
who already hate me or
don't care to love me.
I want to aim my energy at
people who do care to love me.
I want to aim my energy
at people I love and care,
and I want to wrap my
nurturing around them.
So I think that's a part of
this awakening for me, when
we talk about "woke."
My wokeness has more to
do with, I just got to--
I want to love on people,
and I want to nurture people.
Even if we've talked
shit about each other
before, behind each
other's back, that's cool.
That's over there.
Are you OK?
Are you strong?
Are you eating well?
Are you seeking
the help you need?
Are your talents
being given the space
and means to do what they can
do to add to the conversation,
or are you being quieted?
Because sometimes we see
our brothers and sisters
in real pain and
think because they're
acting out in those ways
that that's who they are.
And it really is
that they're in pain.
And we got to go in and be
like, yo, I see you in pain.
May I be of help as
much as I can be.
Or do you just need me to get
out of your way for a while?
And that's cool, too.
But I don't know.
I get tired of trying to aim
my energy at white people, who
may not--
if they don't choose to
love us at this point,
what am I going
to do about that?
Even white gay people.
We're always talking
about the community.
Well, there a lot
of white gay people
who don't like Black people.
You want me--
I'm not going to go and beat
nobody down because they're not
checking for me.
That's cool.
But where are those
little Black kids
who are growing up learning
that it's OK to hate themselves?
How do I get to them?
That's way more important to me.
Yeah.
And I feel like you have done an
extraordinary job of doing that
with Moonlight, with David
Makes Man, of telling stories
of people that could have
been just forgotten and lost
but actually had
something in their spirit
that they wanted
to push forward.
And I think that is-- those
are the important stories that
we need to tell right now,
is what are the stories that
have not been told.
Who are the young people
that are growing up
against crazy odds?
And how do we
amplify their stories
and change the narrative?
Faces, giving a face to
people that aren't seen
and a voice to people
that aren't heard.
And sometimes you've
got to be prepared
to take the criticism for that.
A lot of criticism for Monster's
Ball, an incredible amount
of criticism for Monster's Ball.
An incredible amount of
criticism for Precious.
Just why, Lee?
Why do you have to
show us in this light?
But that is our story.
Because who else is
going to if I don't?
So I'm going to bring
Shawn in because we're
going to add him to ask
a few more questions
and into the conversation.
Lee, Tarell, and Emil, wow.
Thank you so much for this.
Thank you so much
for your honesty
and for your transparency
and for sharing your story.
I've been listening to
everything that you said.
I had two questions.
One, with everything
that you all have
said, where do we go from here?
Where do we as a
community go from here,
working more collaboratively
together in this industry?
And where can we go as
filmmakers and as artists?
Where do we go from here with
everything you guys mentioned?
Right here is a great start.
Where we are right now, in
this space, the fact that we're
having and we're able to have
this conversation and a candid
conversation as
gay men, all of us,
as Black gay men,
all of us, I don't
know that this would have been
heard of through the Academy.
So, Shawn, thank you for
putting this together.
Because where do
we go from here?
We go with people that are
thinking like you, forward
thinkers like you, that are
going to be able to even give
me the courage to
come out and talk
about these things
for the world to see.
And these are private thoughts
that I had been holding on to,
I'm sure Tarell has
been holding on to, too.
But the truth will set you free.
Emil, where do you
feel as though,
with your extensive
experience in media
and understand that
media is a tool--
where do you believe
we can go from here?
Well, I have to
echo Lee's thoughts.
I mean, having
these conversations,
this is where we start, to
have a conversation with four
Black gay men about these
topics and these issues
and these real things
that affect our lives.
I think that is where we begin.
And I am so inspired by both
Lee and Tarell and the work
that you've done, because
you have just pushed away
the old guard and what we would
think Black gay men look like
or how they're depicted.
And you're showing real
humanity and real stories.
And I think that's
the beginning,
and that's where we need to go.
And we need to tap in and let
all these young people have
the opportunity to
tell their stories.
I love that.
And, Tarell, where
do we go from here?
You know, look, I think the
sky's the limit in terms
of where we can go.
I think we--
I hope we go a little
inside for a little bit,
meaning I hope we do a
whole bunch of healing,
a whole bunch of just
introspection, a whole bunch
of uplifting inside.
And I know that may sound a
little kumbaya, a little hold
hands and jump together.
But I really-- again,
I thrive on community.
And I know for our young people,
for our young LGBTQ folks
who are Black to survive,
they need community.
They need elders.
They need to know
the function of them,
but they also need to
know that there is space.
And there's a space in
there of love for them.
And that's the way
we get great art.
That's the way we get the
most compelling stuff.
I mean, sometimes
you actually get it
by pressuring somebody to do--
take the by any means necessary.
And you get good
art that way, too.
But also, what could we get?
Imagine right now
all the young artists
who are queer and Black got
and felt protected enough
and safe enough to
imagine, without thinking
about race, without
thinking about sexuality,
but just imagine what--
imagine, period.
If their brain isn't
thinking about survival,
what else could they
be thinking about?
What dreams may come
if they had the ability
to stop thinking about
their own untimely death
every third thought?
That's what I want for them.
I want that for them.
Thank you.
And the last question is,
you all are very magical,
each one of you.
Tell me a time when you
started to realize your magic.
And, Emil, we can
start with you.
When did you realize your magic?
When did you realize that all
of the things that are you
are adding value to you and
everyone else around you?
I think for me a lot of the time
that I spent at Vibe magazine
really gave me the opportunity
to understand that I could
create space for voices that
weren't going to be heard,
for stories that were
unheard of, and also
to present imagery of Black
people like rock stars,
like the way that we
really see ourselves
but the world doesn't
see us like that.
I think that was the first time.
And then every day with the work
with Native Son, I'm inspired.
I mean, to be able
to see this come
to life and this
conversation and to sit
with Lee and Tarell
and yourself,
I think this is beyond us.
And I think about what
Lee said when it becomes,
it's a God moment.
It's a community moment.
And it is about creating these
spaces and these conversations.
Thank you.
And then, Tarell,
what about you?
When did you start to
realize your magic?
Well, it was a little bit of
rough magic or practical magic,
because one time
I just thought--
my mother had me when
she was 16 years old.
And I think I was
about 12 or 13,
but I just kept trying to
imagine her life if she didn't
have a kid at 16
or 17, like what
her life would have been like.
She was really smart, really
beautiful, and charming,
had all those things
that a model could have.
She was 6 feet tall.
She was slender.
And I was just like, your
life would have been great
if you just didn't have a kid.
And she slapped me.
As we say in Liberty City, she
slapped fire out of my face.
And she was like, if
I didn't want you,
I wouldn't have had you.
And it just made
me think in that--
I mean, I know it sounds weird.
But in that moment, I was like,
oh, no, there was purpose.
She had me on purpose.
I am here for a purpose.
Like, this wasn't an
accidental sort of slip-up.
She was like, no, no, you
were brought here on purpose.
And I remember from that day
on, I just sort of walked
around going, oh, no,
I'm here for something.
There's something
here I'm called to do.
And it just shifted my
view of things radically.
Even in my most
depressing moments,
I can still kind
of feel that slap
and remember that, no,
I'm here for something.
I'm here for a reason.
Wow.
Wow, Tarell.
My mom had me when she was 18.
Wow.
For me it was the--
I think the first couple
of episodes on Empire.
In trying to find your
voice, you don't know--
you know you're an artist,
but you don't really
know what your worth is.
And it was also--
I don't know.
Let me just find myself.
I want to express myself.
But that's a sissy thing to do.
That's not really--
that's not work.
Is that work?
Is that real work?
And so my brother was
in jail during Empire.
And he's three years
younger than me.
And he was embarrassed
about who it was that I was.
And so when you live
with that embarrassment
from your brother
and your father,
you really think that you are--
it affects you deeply.
It affects you.
You are alone.
And three episodes--
we didn't talk.
We still don't really talk.
But three episodes
in, and the numbers
were just going
through the roof.
And people couldn't understand
why people were watching this.
I got a letter from him from
jail and he apologizing.
And I broke down.
And the biggest award that
I've ever gotten was from him.
And he said that
when Empire was on,
the entire prison shut down.
You could hear a pin drop.
3,000 men were glued
to that television.
And I wept when I
got that letter.
I wept.
I didn't return the--
I wanted to write
him back, but I
didn't know how
to write him back
because so much had gone--
we had gone through so much
by then, and we were in our 50s.
But I knew that I had a voice
and that everything that
had put me through, everything
that I'd been through,
that I was communicating to
3,000 men up in that prison.
And they were
focused on my word.
And that's a powerful thing.
I said, oh my god, I got
a little magic in me.
I think it's more than a
little magic, the three of you
on this call.
And I just wanted to say,
on behalf of the Academy
and the members
and everyone who's
going to be tuning
in and participating,
thank you so much
for lending or light,
your transparency, for
sharing your stories.
Emil, we can thank you
so much for moderating
this conversation.
Lee Daniels, as
always, thank you
so much for showing up
and being your true self.
Tarell Alvin McCraney, thank you
all so much for participating
in Academy Dialogues.
Thank you.